we were just talking about our Catholic
upbringing and I was remembering in the
commercial break that I think the most
intense thing for me about Catholicism
when I was a kid was going into
confession and I don't know if you did
that freak you out you you go into that
little room and you have to say the
things that you did that were wrong that
week and I would sort of panic and
sometimes I'd make stuff up because I I
wouldn't really know what to say
and I'd blank and then I would say
something that's weird than anything I
really did you know choke to rabbit and
then there'd be like you know no no I
didn't you know yeah I don't know if you
had any kind of similar I used to go
yeah I did think it was kind of weird
and you could always tell when somebody
was nervous because we would all watch
the kids go in and if they were nervous
that when you would kneel down they the
in sign would light up and then if you
were nervous it would blink from in a
pin out because you could do the kids
like on their knees getting nervous
because they would take pressure off
yeah yes right going back of it but I
would always go like I would always go
Father forgive me frozen I masturbated
this week and he was like oh yeah you
shouldn't do that Bali and then I go in
again Africa yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but then I would go in the week again
after that and I be like I'm sorry
Father forgive me I masturbated again
wait you would say the same thing every
week I was just like I was like is this
really so bad you know I don't think it
was so bad but they said that it was a
sin right so I would just have to keep
repeating it at a certain point to say
like okay go ahead whatever you want to
do go to town yeah yeah so yeah that was
kind of funny
you